thank you very much for talking to Sky
News we meet Brazil's environment
minister Ricardo Salle's in Madrid where
he's attending the UN conference on
climate change his country is under
pressure the world watching in horror
this summer as the Amazon rainforest
burned
president gerbil Cynara accused of
bringing in anti environment policies
that made it much worse if you look at
what he came to office promising to do
rolling back environmental regulation
opening up the Amazon for economic
exploitation isn't it the case that your
government bears responsibility for what
is happening to this crucial ecosystem
didn't begin with what sort of key pass
with some responsibility for it well we
all have responsibilities it's not a
good thing to appoint fingers to
countries or to say to Brazil that you
are doing bad since other countries were
doing bad in the past two in terms of
moral obligation we believe that
countries who are rich in the rich
because they destroy the environment and
also have destroyed the environment
because of the industrial process they
do have this moral obligation in giving
support for developing countries the
Brazil this is about sovereignty and
Economic Opportunity in developing the
Amazon for agriculture and industry is
part of that we must understand that
poverty is the biggest enemy of the
environmental measures and preservation
the argument is though that there is no
point being rich in a world that can't
breathe and the destruction of the
planets lungs is contributing to that
well we're not destroying the current
account in their words lancets it's not
true but it's getting worse but it's
your watch
no it's getting worse because we are not
focusing on the alternatives through the
people who live there at the climate
change conference we meet some
indigenous leaders who do live there
Amazonia illogically winter who Brazil
plenty of them through a translator they
tell me the Amazon belongs to both
Brazil and the whole planet a treasure
that needs recognition and protection
from the Brazilian government who must
recognize its true value to the world
but while president bolson ro is in
power little is likely to change for one
of the world's biggest polluters another
example of the many differences between
the countries gathered here and how
difficult meaningful agreement can be
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News Madrid